[Musique]
l eau les cherry bomb assez la suite ans
après la conférence ce matin là je suis
devant ce voyez france bleu et dans une
demi heure 14h je vais faire une
émission qui s'appelle les petits
bonheurs puisqu'on parle de bonheur
c'est un peu logique en fait puisqu'on
parle de crise ont regardé la personne
qui va apparaître à l'écran j'ai mal au
psg dégueulasse
allam sa voiture
[Musique]
maman
temps beau dire qu'elles sont russes
sexy que jamais regarder non mais je
rêve mais c'est le fait que ces eaux-là
loriol salut les amis oued giroud il a
marqué on était content c'est la fête
mais là et 6h30 je suis fracassé bonne
journée à vous faites attention à vous
j'ai joué en brousse j'ai dit oui
évidemment on va pas mal et de bourse
dans les questionnaires c'est pas bien
et c'est pas bien pas bien les chiens tu
pars d'entente
combien d'abonnés au fait déjà sur
youtube youtube 1,350 million voilà et
ben écoutez on bat et on va parler aux 1
million 300 mille abonnés de la chaîne
youtube
oui dans une autre vie même en chantant
sur une autre maison faut partir pour
partir
parce que j'ai trouvé ce matin sa
direction france télévisions pour aller
à la rencontre des auteurs des
producteurs des réalisateurs de la
collection documentaire apocalypse ça va
cartonner sa voyager à travers le monde
et là il ya un nouvel opus qui sort
effectué par la grosse chambres occupera
la salle ça ressemble et ça ressemble
pas un gueuleton là ce qui m'attend à
des amis prenez soin de vous voilà c'est
la pause c'est la pause
je me régale et je vais pas maigrir mais
je me régale et vous embrasse bonjour et
nien
bonjour christophe dumont jours
christine bâtiment
[Musique]